Graph f of x on
the given domain.
So f of x is equal to 4
times the absolute value
of x plus 6 minus 8.
And the domain is x
between negative 8--
including negative 8.
This bracket means that we're
going to include this endpoint.
And negative 2.
And we're going to
include negative 2.
The bracket means we're
going to include it.
If we didn't want to
include the endpoints
we would use parentheses.
What are the coordinates
of the vertex?
So let's think about
the vertex first.
The vertex you can view it as
the corner of an absolute value
function.
And so it's either going
to be the maximum point
or the minimum point
of the function.
Now over here let's just
think about it a little bit.
When would this hit a
maximum or a minimum point?
Well, we know that the
absolute value of something
is always going
to be nonnegative.
It could be 0.
That's why I'm not
saying that it's always
going to be positive.
It's going to be nonnegative.
So we have something that's
nonnegative right over here.
And then we're multiplying
it times something
that is positive.
So this thing, the whole
expression over here,
nonnegative times a positive is
always going to be nonnegative.
So it's either going
to be 0 or greater.
So this thing is
always going to be
adding to the value of f of x.
So the minimum value
of f of x happens
when this whole thing is 0.
And then when this whole thing
is 0 then f of x is negative 8.
That is the minimum value.
At any other point this thing
is going to be larger than 0.
So let's just think about when
does this whole thing equal 0?
Well, this whole thing is going
to be equalling 0 if x plus 6
is equal to 0.
And when does x plus 6 equal 0?
Well, when x is
equal to negative 6.
When x is negative 6 then
this whole thing is 0
and f of x is equal
to negative 8.
So that's the vertex.
And that's going to
be the minimum point.
This is going to be an
upward opening absolute value
function.
So now let's just draw it.
And what we could
do is, we could
put some points at the vertex.
So let's put some points.
Let's see.
Negative 6, negative 8.
Negative 6, negative
8 is right over there.
Let me scroll down.
Make sure you can
see that point.
Negative 6, negative
8 is right over there.
And I actually want to make you
see the function definition as
well.
Now let's just think about
what it does at the boundaries.
On either side it's
going to be a line.
So when x is negative
8, what is f of x?
Negative 8 plus 6 is negative 2.
Take the absolute value of that.
That is going to be 2
times 4 is 8 minus 8 is 0.
So you have the point
negative 8 comma 0.
And then let's think about what
happens at the other boundary.
When x is negative 2.
Negative 2 plus 6 is 4.
The absolute value of 4 is 4.
4 times 4 is going to
be 16 minus 8 is 8.
So it's going to be the
point negative 2, 8.
And just like that,
I think we're done.
Yes, we are.